une image qui fait toujours plaisir à
voir synonyme de développement
économique et de rayonnement de la
culture martiniquaise dans le reste du
monde
mais derrière ces effets positifs
pourraient se cacher d'autres effets
beaucoup moins intéressants comme la
pollution engendrée par les bateaux de
croisière dans l'air que nous respirons
on sait qu'à marseille le nombre de
particules extrafin mesurer près du
terminal de croisière et 20 fois plus
importants que la normale quand un
bateau est à quai les principaux
polluants qui peuvent être émis par les
paquebots sont le dioxyde de soufre le
dioxyde d'azoté et les particules fines
qui vont avoir des impacts sur la santé
en fonction donc gaz ou particules et
ses impacts vont être soit au niveau de
gêne respiratoire jusqu'à l'an à des
problèmes respiratoires et
cardiovasculaires deux unités mobiles de
surveillance ont été installées par
madininair pour effectuer des relevés en
continu sur la savane et à l'entrée du
quartier de texaco elles resteront en
place jusqu'à la fin de la période de la
présence des bateaux en mars et les
résultats seront analysés puis transmis
durant le second semestre 2010 9 à la
casse m qui a commandé cette étude dans
le cadre de son programme air et de
l'élargissement de ses compétences
touristique
cette étude nous permettra de connaître
précisément quel est l'impact réel des
bateaux de croisière sur la population
et puis après en fonction de ce qu'on
trouvera un communiqué et puis adapté
les actions à mettre en place tout au
niveau du t3
c'est surtout le type de carburant
utilisé par les paquebots qui pourrait
poser problème du fioul lourd peu cher
jusqu'à 3500 fois plus polluant que les
voitures
il faudra donc attendre le second
semestre 2010 9 pour connaître les
résultats de cette évaluation dont on ne
sait pas pour le moment comment ils
seront communiqués à la population